Attention foreigners.
New ruling from the Supreme Court in Spain
that will radically affect asylum applicants
in their possibility these to obtain
labeled arrago.
Arrago Laurel.
Let's just explain.
What does this new ruling say?
Well, it says that asylum applicants,
once they get their application rejected
and issue on appeal,
during the time where they are within
waiting for the resolution of that appeal,
they can say in Spain
and they can work.
But those months that they are working in the country
while waiting for the resolution of the appeal
would not count for the
arrago Laurel.
As you already know,
in order to obtain labour arrago,
you need to demonstrate having work
at least six months in the country legally.
So this time
while waiting for your asylum appeal
would not come.
Why is that?
Well, because
during the time while you're waiting for your appeal,
you are not under a residency status.
You'll be in Spain under a tolerant or permanent status,
which is not the same as residency.
Will be posting and updating you with all the new
updates about this new ruling.
In order to stay tuned, subscribe.